Film Courage: At what point in your career
did you go without work for was it a year?
What happened? Erica Wernick, Personal Coach,
Author and Speaker: That was in 2009 and that
contact, that one connection that I had made
helped me get that first show. But I didn't
have like a huge rolodex of people that I
knew in the industry so it was really challenging
to book another job because as from a graphic
designer standpoint you really need to know
people. Once you get into the union there
is an availability list that you can put yourself
on and you can get some jobs from your name
being on the availability list but people
are only going to that list until they've
exhausted their list of people they know,
so it's so much about who you know and I just
didn't know enough people yet, my pool was
so small. It was like the worst year of my
life because it was also the recession and
so I couldn't even get a waitressing job.
I remember this one day where I saw a Craigslist
posting for a waitress interview a server
interview and I got in my car right away and
drove right over and there were already like
10 people in line and they were only taking
one person so that was really challenging
too and even now I try to get better but I
tend to tie myself worth to how much money
I have and so when I like couldn't even make
a living as like getting a server job or something
like that or any kind of side job um it and
and this was also before Uber and Lyft existed
you know I couldn't drive for Instacart I
couldn't i couldn't do those things it couldn't
be a Postmates person um and so that was really
hard for me too so not only like struggling
to find the work but then time my worth to
that and and feeling so unworthy of success
or anything that i wanted that was really
hard how well do you remember the depression
that you faced oh gosh i very well because
i still experience it all the time like i'm
i think i'm prone to depression i call it
situational depression because it usually
comes from a situation so something happens
um to cause me to be depressed i don't normally
feel it just to feel it with no trigger um
so i recall it very well because i felt it
again many times since then um but it was
just a really pivotal time in my life like
i remember it so well so well i can really
connect you know to those feelings and you
know what i tried to do you know just all
the things that i did and even though it was
almost 13 years ago at this point 12 years
ago i i still remember it very clearly yeah
it was a really rough time for a lot of people
yes it was and i mean thank god i didn't have
kids or didn't have a home you know so many
people lost their homes and you know much
worse than you know fortunately i was able
to stay afloat and you know i had two roommates
at the time and so i was able to still stay
in la which is amazing it could have been
much worse but yeah it was a tough time how
are you able to book a job at the end of all
that i asked for help it was so hard i my
cousin told me a story um it's a short story
i can tell it quickly and people probably
heard it before i forget all the details but
essentially there was a man in his house and
it started raining and as the rain came down
it didn't stop and it started to flood and
he was like oh my gosh how am i going to be
okay and he just kept praying to god god save
me i will be okay please help me god and the
flood kept growing and the rain was getting
worse and so he goes to the upstairs in his
house so he can get to the next level because
it's starting to come into his house and he
sees um someone in their truck drives by and
they're like hey man we can help you come
jump in the truck and he was like no god will
save me i'm going to go upstairs to this upper
level i will be fine and then the rain keeps
coming and the flood is rising and someone
in a boat passes by and they're like hey jump
in the boat we'll help you we'll save you
they see him in this window you know jump
out of your wind and he's like no i'll be
okay i'm praying god will save me and then
finally it becomes like unbearable and he
has to literally climb to the roof of his
house and a helicopter comes and flies over
and drops a ladder and says you know we grab
the ladder we can save you i said no god will
save me i prayed and i know god will save
me and the water rose so much that he couldn't
go anywhere and he ended up drowning and died
and he goes to heaven and he's like god what
the heck i prayed for you to save me why didn't
you save me and god said i sent you a truck
i sent you a boat i sent you a helicopter
and when my cousin told me that story
it really helped me see that like if you're
drowning it's okay to ask for help you know
i felt very ashamed of where i was you know
in my life and how much i was struggling because
again i really tied it to my self-worth and
i just thought you know i'm not a good enough
human being i don't deserve this and so i
don't even deserve somebody's help you know
and i would ghost people's texts you know
i just wouldn't even respond to friends texts
or calls because i was so ashamed i was so
embarrassed you know if they say how are you
what's going on and i would say nothing nine
months later and still nothing is going on
you know i was so ashamed so after my cousin
told me that story i was like okay and so
i reached out to one of the girls that i had
become friendly with from the first show and
i told her look i really need a job if you
know of anyone looking because she was the
same age as me but she had already been in
the industry longer and she knew a lot of
people and so she had found other work i said
i really need a job if you hear of anything
could you let me know and she heard of something
and she recommended me and it was glee and
they called me and they called me a week after
i finally got a waitressing job a week after
and i was like you have no idea how much i
want to come work for you but it was to fill
in for somebody for just a couple days and
i was like you have no idea how badly i want
to say yes to you but i just spent like eight
or nine months with no job and i just got
this waitressing job a week ago i don't think
i can quit this for just a couple days work
even though i really want to and so i said
like if something else comes up longer term
please please call me and a month later they
did and they called me and they said now we
need someone to fill in for the rest of the
season and i gave my notice after a month
of waitressing and i went and worked on glee
wow because that goes back to that energy
shift and so here you had something you finally
got a waitressing job after you know racing
down to an open call for one and then then
this other one opened up so that goes back
to what you're talking about earlier definitely
i mean even just getting the waitressing job
it filled me up so much you know and not even
just self-worth and feeling like wow okay
i finally have some money coming in i can
survive and and i have a job but also being
around other people you know because i was
so afraid to spend money that i wouldn't leave
my room i would stay in my room in my apartment
like all day every day i was afraid to leave
because it would cost me money to leave and
i just i wasn't around people and so that
i think also helped to be around people and
you know waitressing your your hustling and
walking fast and something so i was getting
exercise again and moving my body you know
all of these things that were beneficial that
i think really shifted my energy than to be
open for a tv show very interesting wow what
a story so so when you got the waitressing
job how did that feel because i realized that
wasn't your ultimate destination no it wasn't
but i was elated you know i just needed something
i hadn't had any work in so long i i was so
so happy and so grateful to get that waitressing
job yes wow do you ever go back to that restaurant
well then know now you probably can't because
it's just takeout if it's still around right
well so that so it's funny because so it's
on the block near where i live so i could
walk there and i felt so guilty about like
leaving after just a month and i could tell
the manager was not happy with me that on
glee i was an assistant and i was in charge
of getting lunch every day so i would always
say hey we should go to this restaurant and
so i gave them business and we would order
from the whole office and order lunch there
and i would go there and pick it up because
i wanted to still give them business you know
because i felt so bad about leaving um and
so and i and that restaurant was amazing food
so good but it doesn't exist anymore and another
restaurant is in its place now that's also
a very good restaurant and i go there when
it's open yes that's a great story and and
and even the staff like the people in the
kitchen and the other servers like some of
them i still talk to you to this day some
of them went to the restaurant next door and
i always say hi i get so excited to see them
and it's nice.
Questions For The Viewers: What was the most
helpful part of this video for you?